you mean would you like a story
[Music]
tidbits
well okay well here's a story
for whatever it's worth this is a story
which happened to my brother
years and years ago he and a girlfriend
took uh psychedel took hawaiian wood
rose
up behind boulder colorado in the early
spring
and
they had never taken woodrow's and so
they parked their car and they hiked
down this trail and uh took the wood
rose
and
became hopelessly lost and the the trip
lasted hours longer than they intended
and finally they realized that they were
hopelessly lost it was getting dark
and that they were going to have to
spend the night in the mountains at
about
10 000 feet
behind boulder and that they probably
weren't gonna live through this
experience they had no matches they had
nothing and so then darkness fell
and they had no notion of where they
were and finally just scanning these
valleys and mountains uh
my brother saw
a set of headlights
up on a mountain
and he realized then that there must be
a road
up there
and that if they could climb up
to where he had seen these lights they
might be able to flag somebody down on
this road and save their lives okay so
by this time they had been out in the
in the woods for about
10 hours going through this so they
scramble down into the bottom of this
valley they scramble up the other side
come up
to where they think this road is
and what they discover
is the parking lot
where they left the car
and what they discover is the car's
lights are on
but the car was locked
and the car's lights couldn't have been
on for 10 hours because the battery
would have completely run down the car
still had enough juice that you could
start the engine so the car's lights had
been on no more than a half an hour
[Music]
what does it all mean mr natural well i
think mr natural said it don't mean [ __ ]
i don't know what it means but uh and
there are just endless uh these kinds of
stories
and and some aren't quite so
supernatural but some are more
supernatural
well here's a story i find
i find very very hard to believe but
that was told to me by someone of
impeccable
reputation
this guy was
up in the sierras
somewhere
on a vision quest
and he had made his camp by a little
lake
and um he dropped mushrooms
and uh
a a boloid do you all know what a boloid
is it's one of those big green crackling
meteors that pass over a boloid
came over about an hour into the trip
and disappeared over a nearby hill and
he was just amazed
and the mushrooms were just coming on
and then you know the trip happened and
he was swept away and he basically
forgot about the boloid
and
after a couple of hours of tripping the
mushroom said
now it's time to
walk and he said oh now it's time to
walk and said walk this way and it
directed him and he walked a distance of
about
two or three miles and finally came to
the edge of a
of a lake
and uh
and he couldn't walk any further
and and so he stopped and he was just
standing there contemplating this
circumstance that it had told him to
walk and now he was at the edge of this
lane he was wondering am i supposed to
walk on the water
what is going on here and he looked down
and there was the boloid
and it was it was worth several thousand
dollars he has it he showed it to me and
it was
i mean i mean it's an object from
god knows where i mean just absolutely
screaming with the cosmic abyss and the
karma of the aeon
and if you've ever tried to find
meteorites you know it is something you
cannot look for because they can land
anywhere literally and this guy found
one that weighed over a pound and he
wasn't looking for it he saw it go over
and the mushroom led him to it
stories like that which indicate
not
what they indicate to me is that the
universe is put together in a way that
we don't understand that it is higher
dimensional and we are lower dimensional
and that if you could see the universe
from a higher perspective this man's
finding of the meteor was inevitable
trivial and couldn't have happened any
other way
i'll tell you one more story and then
i'll stop this is not a magical story
this is an almost magical story that
tells you you have to be careful when
judging magic
this happened to me and it relates to
the question about fractals and what
we'll get into this after this evening i
was once with a bunch of people in a
teaching situation like this at a beach
down north of vandenberg air force base
there's a huge beach there that runs for
miles and miles and it's very flat and
smooth
and i was walking on this beach by
myself
and i came upon a little black stone
flat stone about that big around and i
noticed this because it was all sand and
this was the only thing on the beach and
i noticed it and i kept walking
and
after a while
there was another one of these black
stones so similar to the first that
though i wasn't holding the first it
seemed to me it was exactly like it
and i thought about this
and i was i confessed slightly loaded on
mushrooms and so i did something i might
not have otherwise done
i counted the number of steps
between the first stone and the second
stone in other words i turned around and
i walked back to the first stone
and i counted the steps it was like
760 steps
then i walked back to the second stone
and continued walking down the beach and
counted my steps
and 754
steps later
there was the next black stone
sitting on the beach
now what is going on here is this omen
is it magic what is it it's none of this
it's that this bay
was acting like a huge computer
and it was solving
a fractal equation of great complexity
and the solution to the equation was to
deposit a round black stone every every
760 steps give or take eight along this
beach
but if you didn't know about fractal
mathematics if you couldn't see nature
from this point of view you would be
presented with an enigma
you see
and yet what is really happening is that
nature is inviting you to understand
nature is taking you by the hand and
saying you know i'll lift my skirts this
tiny tiny bit do you have enough sense
to look underneath to follow it through
to understand and the psychedelics are
are very similar
and they bring you into a similar
relationship with nature
here's just a little story this is not
supernatural or of quite the character
of the story i just told
but one time i i took something i can't
even remember what it was but it was in
hawaii and i was sitting on a beach
and i was
meditating or thinking or something
and a crab
came along
and i was sitting so still
that the crab cleaned my fingernails for
me
every one of them it just came up to me
and worked its way from finger to finger
to finger until it was done and then it
went on
now you know that's getting into the dao
i would like to believe
[Music]
you